[Music]
I've never seen a movie like this
we're revving to give you everything we
got
we got something special so let's
celebrate that it's the end of the road
so we're going back to the roots of Fast
and Furious
then I go what kind of trouble can we
get into this time everything is bigger
better and hits you like a right hand of
the jaw
it is True Entertainment on a massive
canvas you're about to learn all about
fear with a new villain with new Stakes
real steak I haven't played a villain in
probably 10 years all right dorks what
are we blowing up I wanted to bring
something to the lineage that hadn't
been done yet he just comes in guns
blazing you guys are going to hell
Dante is really one angry guy we're
really well dressed to face off against
Tom and his family you had to be a
certain psychotic he's coming for you
with everything
there's something coming and dumb knows
it I can't think of a better time for
him to be at a Crossroads never accept
that
we're all feeling unsure at the moment
even down
we haven't been as successful as we're
used to seeing this team be and that's
kind of scary
this sets the stage for something larger
so it's unfamiliar territory that's the
problem with having such a big family
how do you choose the ones you save
I really am looking forward to the
toretos being back together again we're
firing on all cylinders
is it exciting yes
he's trying to tear us apart is it
nerve-wracking hell yeah this is the
magic of fast Let's Race it's showtime
we go it's the beginning of the end it's
the sum of everything we've loved in the
Fast and Furious Universe here they come
it's exciting to be a piece in the
puzzle of something that's so very
important pop culture I do suggest for
the audience out there to prep it's a
big one for a saga to be complete it
must have an end it's bittersweet but
here I say more meaningful
you know we'd already be there if Roman
wasn't driving Fort Knox on wheels
shining baby
we're locked inside it's a trap that's
the bomb all right dorks what are we
blowing up what the Vatican
I start going to hell
the great Dom Toretto if you never would
have gotten behind that wheel
I'd never be the man I am today and now
I'm the man that's going to break your
family peace
by peace the devil's coming boom
ing I knew you would come for me well
how about we all just start shooting
each other
let's take some Graves
you are not to be trusted are you in on
my Christmas list either
calvary's here
we need weapons
and cars
adding cars do you like surprises I
adore them
I'd stay down if I was you you'll need
to hit me harder for that
the game's overdone you lose
this is your last ride
hahaha you might want to buckle up
it's been 22 years since we started this
Saga how did we get so lucky to come so
far
this family is ready to come back
together it's a dream come true I mean
it's definitely bucket list for sure oh
we're at the Apex of his franchise fast
the heart and soul of The Fast and
Furious franchise boots on the ground on
location the more movies we make the
bigger they get we continue to outdo
ourselves because we owe it to our fans
the enormity of everything hits you like
a right hand of the jaw you still know
how to drive every time I'm on set I
have to pinch myself
I just have been badgering them to
participate in this it's such an honor
to be part of his family that's the
problem with having such a big fan how
do you choose the ones you save so lucky
to be able to continue this Saga and
fall of you
[Music]
I know that this road has been very hard
and yet here you are building This
Magnificent family
what's going on in that head of yours
something little basic
they're dead they're not afraid of
anything
but I am
afraid of losing someone I love
Dominic Toretto you're about to learn
all about fear
you built such a beautiful life filled
with love and family I never got that
chance
you stole that from me
my future
my family
and now
I'm gonna break yours
by peace
[Music]
[Applause]
he's coming he's coming for you with
everything
what's the plan Dom I'm not sure anymore
one of us might not come back from this
but we have to fight
never accept death when suffering is old
[Music]
foreign
that's the problem with having such a
big family how do you choose the ones
you save
Let's Race
[Music]
[Applause]
you still know how to drive
what do you think
it's showtime
[Music]
recognizes game
I'm coming for you son
thank you
[Music]
here they come you will never be able to
break my family
[Music]
good morning sunshine you gotta be
kidding me
[Music]
all right